foreign
is in Atlanta hi Caitlin welcome to the
Ramsey Show
good afternoon how are you sir better
than I deserve Merry Christmas how can
we help
um so I am wondering I have about 17 000
saved up personally and
um I was wondering if I should 9000 is
my uh three or my six-month emergency
fund and I would like to buy a car
because I need something a little more
professional for my business and
um I was wondering how much of that
remaining uh would 8 000 I should use to
buy car or should I you know put off
buying that car and
um start a Roth IRA because I've been
putting that off as well
what's your income
um my income is 33 600. so what is your
profession that you need to look more
professional for
so I own a landscaping company and
um the truck that I've been driving that
looks professional
um will be going to my new crew and so I
need a vehicle while they're using that
truck to work to go run estimates and
errands and stuff like that
okay all right well
um I've had a professional landscaper
doing my office work and my lawn
personal lawn for uh 20 21 years I do
not know what he drives
okay nor do I care
okay all I really care about does a
dadgum lawnmower work
exactly
Caitlyn do you know what I drive
uh what do you guys it's an
embarrassment to me and my family it's
an embarrassment to all of us but you
don't know that's that's the point right
that's the point right you know you now
know it's an embarrassment it's not not
great it's not great so no I I would not
look professional I would buy something
that's reliable and that gets the job
done that's what you always want to do
in business uh there's very few things
in business that you buy to impress
people that work
most of the things that you buy in
business should just give you a return
on investment meaning they should get
the job done for the cheapest possible
dollar so get you a nice little truck
that's dependable that'll do the
estimates and that's all you need and if
you ever lose a customer
due to the truck you drive you call me
and I will pay what he would have paid
you to cut the grass it will never
happen man this is the Ramsay show